it's not one of the most important but
it's never on sale
and how much is that
14.90
[Music]
this one should be 26.50 these are ready
and are around 3 500.
um
around 4 000 at most it's calf skin with
embryo dairy otherwise there's python
skin ranging from 3000 to 5000
how about this crocodile skin bag it's
the ultimate precious bag and that's 29
29 000 euros
[Music]
luxury designers famous worldwide aren't
feeling the economic squeeze
and in the fashion capsule people crowd
in
even on a normal weekday afternoon
our journey starts in the temple of
milan's designer labels the fashion
district the queen of via montenegro
the identity of this brand is based on
the craftsmanship of the florentine
masters and the leather goods are its
prestige sector the same goes for
bottega veneta recalling the plating of
the leather goods manufacturers from
vicenza italian labels owned by the
french and together with ysl and other
caring group labels are invoicing in
switzerland
[Music]
how much are these
1290
the same price 14.90
15.80
today we did all kinds of brands louis
putin
foreign mainly we did a lot of jimmy
choo
what have you manufactured recently high
boots they gave me 40.
[Music]
are they from the latest winter
collection
gucci even gave me the sewing machine
are you using it
yes we made a lot of boots with that
gucci is always asking for boots or
sandals
how many do they give you every day
about 100 pairs but they're complicated
just gucci every day 100 pairs
the man we talk to is a subcontractor
and inside this workshop the luxury
shoes are made
the designer design the model makers do
prototypes but the big fashion house
turned to high-level firms which
assigned the job to subcontractors the
craftsman for the actual production
our first stop to find out who is suing
the luxury bags and shoes is riveria del
brenta venice the shoe industry center
of excellence italy's flagship
the shoemaker store advised us to come
here they said you make shoe uppers
yes
of this model
the upper is the visible part of the
shoe
sewing it is the most important
manufacturing step in shoe making
the chinese specialize in this
production
[Music]
how much do they pay you for this
to talk about prices he makes us move
away from the work benches because the
amount he gets from the supplier is not
the same of what he pays to the worker
who is suing the shoes
we get 23 for this
i told the worker let's say that i give
four to them and six to me we usually
set the prices this way with ferragamo
the prices goes higher
how many can they make
every day 25 pairs
you pay them by the shoe
they keep working day and night so they
can make more
if you're saying that we're not
legitimate almost all the chinese work
this way it's useless to tell us that we
are not legitimate
payments by pair of shoes and piecework
is illegal if the shoe factory gives the
chinese 23 euros the worker is paid 4
euros to make a pair of boots and it's a
model by ferragamo of the current
collection
they're from the latest runway
you're counting a lot on these boots
this year how much are they
15.50
is it the difficulty of this production
deciding the price
yes that's because our shoes are still
almost entirely handmade
these are made in florence
our headquarters are in florence we make
them here
this also justifies the price
who gives you the san loron orders
the sonoran supervisor came to the
workshop to check
i'll show you one model
this model with the circles and ankle
strap
this model has been around for two years
would you like to try them on
how much are they
6.75
[Music]
we are talking about the tribute sandal
an iconic model by ysl worn on the red
carpet by adriana lima kaylee minnow
jennifer lopez julia roberts beyonce
they pay you nine euros a pair how many
pairs
for ten thousand nine euros just for the
upper and another four euros
how much would a legitimate italian
craftsman cost
a lot probably
given that since 2000 150 local upper
manufacturers closed down and 300 new
chinese workshop opened at that time
we met on the condition of anonymity a
subcontractor manufacturer who had
always sewn designer shoes
the gucci boot i showed you is sold
between 1300 to 1800 euros for that
gucci boot they gave me 60 euros the
brand pays 180 to the shoe manufacturers
that gives me the job that's 10
that's why they don't want people to
know that the actual cost of the luxury
shoes materials and manufacturer is 10
to 15
at the most of the final price all
inclusive
special
assembly general expenses box everything
of that 10 paid by the brand the
manufacturers represent a cost between
40 and 60
it also depends on the type of
manufacturer and the type of shoe a
court shoes will take 22 minutes to make
for a gucci court shoe they will give me
9 euros
the cost of a craftsman is calculated
per minute but the processing time may
vary between 20 minutes and four hours
depending on the shoe
it's the labor costs the cost of those
who make the shoes that will get lower
they will strangle you on labor costs
because the chinese will cut them by
half
how can they ask for half of the
production costs because instead of
eight hours they'll double their working
hour or they get paid under the table
they are boycotting us on hourly rates
if i'm legitimate i cannot ask for less
than 18 to 20 euros per hour
they keep asking to lower our prices and
we the subcontractors feel trapped
indeed for the ysl sandal the legitimate
manufacturer cost would be around 30
euros the chinese told us he gets 9
euros plus 4 euros for the coating and
that's less than half
whose manufacturing cost was estimated
at 30 euros in one day this price has
considerably lowered
only for the shoe upper i should decided
15 is fine
yes
eight
good you can do it right
if i do it as for the luxury brand eight
euros
on the international level there isn't a
law forcing fashion house to control
their production chain
at the moment only gucci has pledged its
social responsibility with the ethical
certification sa 8000
this means ensuring the customer and
improving the company's reputation that
their products were made respecting the
rights of the workers across the entire
chain of suppliers and subcontractors
in recent years some of the caring group
brands have been more careful regarding
the production
someone from the upper management wants
to check what happens then
the show factory gives us some of the
shoes in small quantities so they can
come to us for their inspection and show
they are working with good craftsmen we
are only a front
but then the big quantities go to the
chinese
who's to blame if the prices are too low
the brand names at the head of the chain
or those who subcontract
the shoe factory is signing a contract
with the main office
it's hard to determine the legal
responsibilities without the
transparency of the production chain
this way as long as sweated labor is
concerned
the company can just shrug and say i
knew nothing about it
there is a connivance of the brands in
this because they are the ones imposing
the prices the factories must work for
it is no longer the factories making a
quote and proposing it but it's the main
office that will impose a production
rate then the factory will have to
recoup within the production chain it's
their problem
we're talking about a product that has
such a high markup that all the workers
could make a good living
we were asking for more transparency in
the production chain then again it takes
two to reach an agreement
they never approved it
our proposals were never accepted
[Music]
they said the factory had closed down
but it kept working the chinese are
still there and they never take a
vacation
the dismissal was motivated by the
termination of the company i was also
told saturday he'll work for eight hours
for free i refused
right away to threaten me they fired a
worker
we want to work it's our right to work
legally
we are in the center of florence a group
of thirteen synagogues workers is
demonstrating in front of the building
of regina toscana
their contract was not renewed after
they asked to legalize their working
positions
the company in question is poseta a
chinese-run firm specialized in
metalwork
but not of any middle work we are
talking about the designer buckles of
luxury brands
the firm gets worked directly from the
first level right in front of them
our firm is here with that red gate in
the back there is poseta workshop
in the offices right here in front of us
that's right
what happens after all the original
buckles arrived
they take them there we work on them and
they go back where they came from
how many items a day are you working on
one day i did 3 350 items they were
buckled for bags
abdul's task is the lathering
it means staying for hours bent over a
tub polishing the buckles for designer
bags and shoes
and it's a very hard job
we did a lot of different brands
prada gucci
giorgio armani
hermes
[Music]
i work 11 hours monday through friday
on saturday i give them six hours
nobody pays me for them
the word gift was used by them
that's what they're telling you gift me
or i'll send you away
the chinese law rules
[Music]
but not only a gifting system of
overtime was in place
part of the paycheck about 200 euros a
month was given back under the table
they take everything away from you
but a regular contract stays in place
you have to give them back the cash
for instance when you go to the bank it
looks as though they duly paid you
everything then you have to go get that
money and give it back to them
you get to the atm and get the money
if you do it they renew your contract
and if you don't they send you away
this is called extortion but this way
your paycheck is clean
i'd like to talk to the owner of
positive if i may
he doesn't want to do the interview
could i talk to mr bingzi
there is no one by the name
isn't he the owner of one of these three
firms i don't know goodbye
we are here on the premise of the same
firm that was closed down and formerly
had another name
only the minority of the single lease
workers was brave enough to turn to the
labor unions
no complaint ever came from 100 or so
chinese workers
the chinese know about the firm and
their home they don't care about
anything else
they hire chinese people husbands and
wives they took work 13 hours a day
how do they chinese live do they sleep
there in the parking lot
do they sleep in the car
that's where they live
producing in florence has an added value
the tuscan territory has a great
manufacturing tradition regarding both
leather and metalwork
so much so that gucci made that its
forte in an advertising campaign
instead of bringing the work to china
they brought the chinese here they
reversed the course
it's no coincidence if the issue after
taking to the streets involving the
government and especially the newspapers
subsided with the reinstatement of the
dismissed workers
nevertheless these are the luxury
workers and these are their homes
but the fact that the production workers
come out of the woodwork to assert their
rights is an exception
especially where jobs are scarce
naples is our last stop
it's one of the most important italian
leather districts
the napoleon craftsmanship tradition is
famous worldwide
for which brands did you experience the
worst conditions
which was too much
fendi
too much referred to the conditions
they make you sign a three-hour contract
they pay you very little when they want
to and how they want to a contract for
three hours
three hours a day
and how long did you work eight hours or
even longer
what about the wage
real low 30 euros a day
the final paycheck
500 600 470.
you only did gucci
for gucci for five years in this field
i've been working for 25 years
how old were you when you started 12 13.
in 25 years working as a dire at
subcontractor factories the worker
talking to us dyed the leather of bags
and purses for major fashion houses
his testimony courageous for accepting
to tell us is only an example of a
situation labor unions describe as
desperate
but when a factory has dozens of
three-hour contracts
how can nobody suspect that it might be
sweated labor
i just cannot believe that the main
office has no idea of such a situation
when the size of the phenomenon of
sweated labor of underpayment lack of
rights is so huge that it covers the
vast majority of luxury workers how can
they not know
it's impossible not to know they could
tell me it's none of my business
i gave them work
it's the factories who are responsible
i'm washing my hands of it
we are in the outer northern outskirts
of naples beyond scampia and second
decline
around cassandrino
[Music]
all neighboring municipalities the
leather factories are gathered most of
them aren't direct suppliers but
subcontractors where you may find the
most difficult situations this one in
via paolo barcelino is the most visible
built up area the rest of the factories
are hard to detect
most of the factories around here are
like this yellow one here it is simply
the ground floor of the houses where
someone else live just go inside the
courtyard and you'll see on the ground
floor instead of a garage there's a
small leather goods shoes or even
clothing factory
we find factories who only work
illegally they are not registered they
almost don't exist but in this case as
well we're talking about thousands of
workers
in this area it's hard to find factories
where workers earn at least a minimum
wage it's a rarity when you do find one
when the gucci inspectors were expected
they said they will be here tomorrow
clean up the factory
and the gucci inspectors would come
yes but two days before we were notified
that the inspectors would come we
obviously had to wear our coats ear
protectors goggles the factory was so
clean as we could only dream for the
rest of the time
as soon as they left everything turned
back as it was
they weren't going to ask the workers
directly how much do you make a day how
many hours are you working
we are our rights we work for you but
what are you giving to us
the situation is out of control that we
are stricken by one story in particular
where they make counterfeit items a
business notoriously in the hands of the
organized crime sometimes they also
receive the real stuff
there was a seized workshop we worked
inside i didn't know the name of my
employer he used to call us with a
disposable cell phone
excuse me what is your name
what's it to you
he used to pay us in his car he'd take
the money from an envelope or a box on
the back seat
we used to make counterfeit items
but you did realize you were also making
the real stuff
sometimes we did
how could you tell
a little tab inside was missing from the
counterfeit
the manufacturing was identical
identical same material same stitching
same color same manufacturer
didn't they tell you make them better
no they were just the same
how long did you work
four five months and they still owe 100
euro the counterfeit was better
[Laughter]
we're talking about products of
incredible value but those who make them
are treated under third world conditions
when i am accusing a company for the
transparency of its supply chain and the
wages because i'm suspecting they are
low but i don't know for sure i am
accusing it because they are doing all
they can do to save money
and they are jeopardizing the factories
they hired because if the factory owners
hardly scrape by there's nothing they
can do
you are jeopardizing the worker as well
they're putting money before anything
else even before people's dignity if
that's not a problem
you